hey 42 here on average American doctors
interrupt their patients within 14
seconds welcome to RIF digestive
biscuits have no particular digestive
qualities in the US it is illegal to
sell them under that name most diamonds
are at least 3 billion years old by
dictionary definition a Smout is a small
unimportant Scottish person London with
a population of over 8.3 million is not
actually a city although the City of
London with a population of just 7,000
is it is illegal to attempt to swim the
English Channel from France because of
the 500 plus vessels that traversed a
narrow stretch of water everyday the
ozone layer smells faintly of geraniums
1/3 of Russians believe that the Sun
revolves around the earth when the Mona
Lisa was stolen from the Louvre in 1911
one of the suspects was Picasso on
average every square mile of C on the
planet contains 46,000 pieces of rubbish
one in ten European babies is conceived
in an Ikea bed thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42